I think we have a lot
of preconceptions
about what race really is.
What is race has changed
dramatically through time.
There is no official scientific
definition of race.
We're all different.
I was aware that I wasn't white.
The teacher said,
"No, no, Tess is something else."
And everybody's eyes are on me,
and I'm a really shy person.
She said, "But what are you, Tessa?"
A lot of people imagine that there is
some biological tangibility to race,
because we use it so much.
Race really is a social construct,
but just because something
is a social construct,
that doesn't mean it doesn't have
meaning in people's lives
like money, or the nation state,
or democracy,
or all these other things
that define how we live,
but are also constructed.
It influences what you're eating,
it influences the type of healthcare
you have access to,
the type of schooling
how people feel about you.
I mean, it's a powerful marker
for all of these things
that we care about when
we're trying to run a society.
Race has never been something
that I don't have to think about.
It's put on to us.
When you look at the history
and origins of this idea,
you start to see it
for what it really is,
which is the manifestation of power.
People imagine that people have
always thought about skin colour
in this racialised way,
and we really haven't.
That idea is no more than
a few hundred years old.
It's not really until the age
of colonialism, in the 17th Century,
that you start getting the idea that
each continent has its own
individual kind of people.
It arose at a very specific
moment in history.
In the 17th Century,
you're taking long trips by ship,
and you're struck by
how different people look
than you remember them
when you got on.
So this is the first edition
of Systema Naturae,
so the Systems of Nature.
And for man, Linnaeus distinguishes
four varieties,
these varieties correspond
to the four continents.
Where it really changes is in the
10th edition of Systema Naturae.
This is the foundation
of scientific racism.
He brings in moral character,
so the American
is "red and choleric,"
and stands up straight.
The European, "white, sanguine,
and muscular"
The Asian, "sallow, melancholic
and stiff"
The African, "black,
phlegmatic and lazy"
So these stereotypes have endured
through the ages.
If you're going to take
a group of people,
and you're going to decide that
they're not people anymore,
then you need something
to justify that.
You can be defined very differently
depending on the country
that you're in,
or the time that you're in.
And that's how these categories
have always been used.
They are political tools
that change depending
on their usefulness
to whoever is doing
the categorisation.
We are one of the most homogeneous
species on the planet.
Humans have far less genetic
variation than chimpanzees do.
And yet, those chimpanzees look
the same to me.
There were never any "pure" races,
there is no gene that exists
in all the members of one race
and not another.
There is no black gene,
there is no white gene.
Human groups overlap completely
in their genetic variation.
In the same way that you're related
to your family,
you can get a kind of
fuzzy genetic similarity.
But when you get to
the continental level,
which is really where
we're talking about race,
that genetic similarity is so fuzzy,
and so statistically weak,
as to be almost meaningless.
We have this envy of fields where
things are hyper-simplistic.
We want to be able to look
at a genome and say
that people are these kind
of concrete immutable things,
that cannot be changed.
Genetics doesn't work that way,
it's the product of many genes
interacting with each other
and their environments.
To fully answer the question about
what a living thing is
it's going to be about much more
than genes.
If I were to go out
on to the street today
and find someone
of Indian heritage like myself,
and randomly then pick someone
who is not of Indian heritage,
it is perfectly
statistically possible
for my genome to have more
in common with that person
who isn't of Indian heritage
than that person who is.
Even though race itself
is a construct,
racism is real and we are not
in a post-racial society.
Race keeps making itself
and power keeps making race.
Even though we know that
race isn't biological,
we've been living with this idea
of it being real
for so long that it means that people
who do have a shared racial identity
have now cultural similarities
which has been born out of hardship,
but it's still beautiful
and important.
The biology of race
is not a useful concept.
I have a different
historical trajectory,
I love the African
American tradition,
but it's not better than
anybody else's,
it's just the one that I'm a part of.
I don't think we're going
to stop classifying people,
because I think that's how
we make sense of the world.
I think every generation
is going to classify people
according to the criteria that
are politically important to them.
I don't think we need to find
new boxes to put people in,
I think we now have
the opportunity to say,
we understand that all of these
things are a spectrum,
in a way that we hadn't
considered before.
So instead of finding new ways
to categorise people
we can just find new ways
to exist better together.
Race is a story that's handed down
and handed around.
But we can choose
the stories that we tell.